hey everyone in this week's episode
we'll talk about the most popular and
commonly used programming language
python so let's begin and learn about
the development of python and gain
insights about the current it Trends but
before that make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to get
notified every time we come up with new
content python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax co-readability
and english-like commands that make
coding a lot easier and efficient due to
this it is the most popular and
preferred language python has
interpreted high level general purpose
programming language developed by Widow
and rossim at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after this week python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus Guido and Rossum
formulated python in the late 1980s as a
successor to the ABC language in 1994
python version 1.0 was released with
features like exception handling Lambda
map filter and reduce python 2.0
released in 2000 introduced features
like list comprehensions and a garbage
collection system capable of collecting
reference Cycles python 3.0 was released
on the 3rd of December 2008. undoubtedly
Python 2.x and 3.8 have proven to be the
most used versions as of today python
3.7.4 has the latest stable version
released in the summer of 2019. python
is popularly used for development
scripting and software testing top ID
companies like Google Facebook Instagram
Spotify and Netflix among others use
Python some major applications of python
can be seen in the fields of machine
learning artificial intelligence data
science and iot python also offers many
libraries like numpy SCI
site Keras tensorflow Django and flask
pept 8 is the official style guide that
defines the styling conventions for
python code a few popular open source
python projects include pit EnV
statistics solving the traveling
salesman problem using self-organizing
maps and python to BPF converter some of
the trending python repositories on
GitHub today include NLP ml from scratch
pytotch Transformers 100 days of ml code
among others popular websites on the
internet like Reddit and quora are built
using python civilization 4 Battlefield
2 Sims 4 and World of Tanks are some
popular games developed using python
according to indeed the average salary
of a python developer in India is about
5 lakhs per annum and that in the US is
around 124 000 US Dollars users and
admirers of python especially those
considered knowledgeable are referred to
as pythonists pythony stars and
pythonians since its Inception python
has come a long way to become the most
popular coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry python is
a widely popular programming language
that is used for web development game
development data analysis as well as
data visualization
hi everyone
welcome to this python developer full
course by simply loan in this session we
will cover all the important python
Concepts techniques and projects that
will help you become a successful python
developer a highly experienced trainers
will take you through this live session
but before I begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
so we will start by learning the history
of python and understand the top 10
reasons to Learn Python you will look at
the job role of a python developer the
skills they need to possess and how the
resume of a python developer should be
then we'll see how to install Python and
the Anaconda distribution of python
then we will shift our Focus towards
learning the basics of python such as
data types variables operators lists
tuples and dictionaries next we will
understand about loops and conditional
statements after that we'll get an idea
about object oriented programming
Concepts and functions in Python we will
also cover some important Advanced
Python Programming Concepts such as
iterators modules generators as well as
packages finally we will see the
important python interview questions
that are often asked so let's get
started let's begin and learn about the
development of python and gain insights
about the current ID Trends python is
very famous for its simple programming
syntax core readability and english-like
commands that make coding a lot easier
and efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language
python has interpreted high-level
general purpose programming language
developed by Guido van rossim at
National Research Institute for
mathematics and computer science
Netherlands in contrast to popular
belief that python was named after the
snake python was actually named after
the show Monty Python's Flying Circus
Guido and Rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the ABC
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling Lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference Cycles python 3.0
was released on the 3rd of December
2008. undoubtedly Python 2.x and 3.x
have proven to be the most used versions
as of today python 3.7.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top ID companies like Google
Facebook Instagram Spotify and Netflix
among others use Python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi Keras tensorflow
Django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code a few
popular open source python projects
include pip EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing match and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytotch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry so what
really is Python programming language
python is an object-oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it's supposed multiple programming
paradigms such as structured object
oriented and functional programming
python is often described as batteries
included language because it has a
comprehensive collection of standard
libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by Guido van Rossum
and its implementation started in
December 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994 python 2.0 came out in October
2000 while python 3.0 was released in
December 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the Python programming language let's
now look at the top 10 reasons why you
should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons to like
python is that it is quite easy to learn
and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves readability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial
machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session compared to Java or CC plus plus
it has fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in Java as you can
see
if you have to write a program in Java
you first have to declare the class name
along with its scope
next using curly braces you need to pass
the main method along with its arguments
and then using system.out.print element
method you can print hello world that's
quite a tedious task isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here you can write
the print function and pass whatever you
want to display inside the brackets and
that will print the output it is so
simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at 9 we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language python has large
community support
it has an extensive and active Community
to assist Engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum the
community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack Overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners
python enhancement proposals or pep is
where the proposals and the improvements
are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the design of
python written by Tim petos that
represents the guiding principles for
python development
up next at 8 we have portable and
extensible
multiple cross-language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example if the users have a python
code written on Windows and they want to
execute on a Mac operating system or
Linux operating system or Solaris they
can easily do it without any Amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without any
interrupt
its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java.net C and C plus codes with
python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a
cross-platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next Reason To Learn Python is
testing Frameworks
python supports several built-in
Flawless testing tools and Frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and Frameworks
supported by python are Pi test selenium
and Splinter
this is the reason for which every
tester tries to use python-based tools
and Frameworks to test any application
or code or to validate it in an easier
manner pie test is the most recommended
testing framework for functional
integrational and unit testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
Python programming language to automate
various tasks and Splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting URLs and interacting
with their items
at number 6 we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
task simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
Frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation web
development machine learning and data
science
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via python
package index the repository of python
software python provides the default
package called pip Anaconda is a
third-party python ecosystem other
examples include numpy scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later further it is
interpreted by the machine and checked
for errors at runtime
the machine is used to read and
interpret the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program or the
same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number 4 we have web development
another reason to Learn Python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
Frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are Django flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie Etc
these Frameworks are written in Python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in PHP
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scraping
Django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out URL routing Etc
once the user establishes the framework
all these features become ready to use
flask is a microwave framework written
in Python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
Pinterest and Linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask it will assist users with URL
routing and authentication support
turbo gears is a highly recommended and
scalable framework that supports
features such as authentication caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world around
us
python is one of the most preferred
programming languages for machine
learning because of its simple syntax
and support for several machine learning
libraries
using different libraries and functions
in Python the system can learn and train
itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand python is robust scalable
and provides extensible visualization
and Graphics options hence it is widely
used in data science
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas for
operations to manipulate data on
numerical tables and time series it also
provides simply for symbolic computation
and sci-fi for Technical and scientific
computations
it has another Library called Pi brain
which is sought for python-based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network library
scikit-learn is the machine learning
library for creating classification
regression and clustering algorithms and
finally it provides Pi torch and
tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to Learn Python which is
career opportunities and salary
Python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and Promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it has been used by most of the tech
Giants
industry leaders using python are Amazon
Google Facebook IBM NASA Netflix and
YouTube
next you can see the Google Trends
but I have considered three programming
languages python Java and C plus I have
compared them for the past 12 months you
can see it clearly on your screens that
python has become a front runner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in Python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the YouTube
search
there also you will find that Python
programming language is the most
searched language on YouTube
now on your screens
you can see the report of pypl which is
popularity of programming language index
it is created by analyzing how often
language tutorials are searched on
Google
it is a leading indicator the raw data
comes from Google Trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
Java then JavaScript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph shows the popularity of
python and Java over the years starting
from 2004 till the current period which
is 2020 worldwide python is the most
popular language
python grew the most in the last five
years by 19.4 percent and Java lost the
most by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into If You Learn
Python language
first
you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third-party web
services
second
you can become a web developer here you
will be responsible for writing
server-side web application logic python
web developers usually develop back-end
components connect the application with
third-party services and support the
front-end developers by integrating
their work with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python as a data analyst you
have to gather data from multiple
sources using scripts analyze that data
develop and Implement databases and data
collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best Solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of Scopes If You Learn
Python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job roles
so if you become a python developer you
can earn an average salary of 76 526
dollars per annum in the United States
while in India you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
If You Learn Python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of
hundred and thirteen thousand dollars
per year in the United States while in
India you can earn an average of 10
lakhs 28 000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number nine we had active community at
eight we had the portable and extensible
feature of python at number seven we saw
the testing Frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at five we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
sense at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer let's
answer this so here are some of the
Technologies used by a python developer
pandas Anaconda tensorflow python Ides
Django web framework and patreon a
python developer is one Who develops
backend components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web Frameworks like
Django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science so basically a python
developer develops deploys debugs and
maintains a project so let's go through
the skill set of a python developer now
the core python skills that a python
developer possesses are data structures
like arrays list stack queues trees and
graphs there's oop Concepts like
inheritance classes and objects and
abstraction thus packages and functions
that is importing external packages into
a python code database and its
connection that is connecting a python
backend to a database like MySQL when it
comes to data science skills there's
numpy that is a library for performing
mathematical calculations
let's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this scipy and then there's
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised Etc now coming to web
developer skills there are Frameworks
like Django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's API handling which is basically
handling API requests for a web
application to perform server-side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
back-end part of a web application
usually handled by python Frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up is python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
Frameworks like Django and flask
collaborates with the data team together
end users requirements develops the
server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
Improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlip
numpy pandas Etc carry out data analysis
collect by using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including Pi test Pi unit perform
complex system tests troubleshoot code
issues create test scripts design the
automation framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles to perform statistical
analysis of data put machine learning
models into production research and
transform data science prototypes
research and Implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability Improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software Engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe the average salary of a
python developer in India is around 7
lakhs 55 000 rupees per annum the
average salary of a python developer in
the US is about 79 000 US dollars per
annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for and do not write anything
extra that's a big no the recruiters are
smart enough to know that so do not lie
and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the fresher resuming so if
you're a fresher these are some of the
points that you need to know
first you have the resume header now the
summary is supposed to be clear and
concise just say what exactly you want
and some of your strengths next is the
profile links and your portfolio so you
can mention your LinkedIn profile link
and also your GitHub repository link if
you have next up is the projects now
clearly depict the goal of your project
so just in case you worked on like C5
projects make sure you keep it concise
and crisp next up is your education do
not lie here make sure you give a
relevant education with grades next you
have the certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down next you have the
technical skills now again prioritize
according to the job role and lastly you
have your non-technical skills this
could be your communication analytical
skills problem solving skills Etc moving
on to an experienced developer so again
mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links coming to
experience now here you'll have to
clearly depict your work you'll have to
make sure that you write down all your
responsibilities in that company do not
go overboard and write extra keep it
very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job role and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as I mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
Python we since python is open source as
as I had already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in in Python
and we create it in a particular system
on Windows we don't need to make any
changes if we wanted to use the same
script or this that same piece of code
on some other system say on a Linux
system or a Mac system python itself
comes with a very large standard Library
this this facilitates us a lot because
we don't need to create our own
libraries or modules or have to download
very specific libraries most of the
problems that we do encounter uh quite
commonly can already be solved by the
standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python right right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will encounter what is the meaning of a
data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and as as
you will see later python has one of the
most user-friendly data structures that
can be found in any language especially
compared to some of its contemporaries
now python is a dynamically programmed
language and this is very important and
what this means is that in most
compiler-based languages we there are
certain processes that can only happen
during the compilation stage so what a
dynamic programming language does is it
takes all those compilation specific
tasks and processes and it does it for
us as we actually type the code so we
don't need to waste time or spend extra
time to do something that would
otherwise be needed to be only done in
compilation we would have to set out
specific runtime just for that so this
allows us to create our programs and
solutions much faster and allows us to
debug much easier and yeah so it's a
it's a very important feature about
python Now quickly I will just go over
some of the areas of python where like
areas of or different domains where
python is very heavily implemented and
the first one the first few ones that
come to reminder like web development
and Ai and machine learning so you have
Technologies like Django and Flash that
are built on top of python that I use
extensively for web development when it
comes to something like artificial
intelligence or machine learning you
have distributions such as Anaconda you
have pandas and many other libraries
like scipy and numpy that are used
extensively too so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
used in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays because of again some
of the libraries that I have already
mentioned such as sci-fi interestingly
if you are into game development or
gaming in general you would see that
python actually has certain libraries
and certain technologies that facilitate
game development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop be
creating desktop guise image processing
graphic design applications and
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses uh there are many Technologies
in the environment of python that were
almost designed for the specific purpose
of being able to present certain
Concepts or to be able to teach certain
classes and I can't think of too many
programs or too many environments
outside of python that are better to
solve these Education and Training
course related problems and situations
let's uh let's get to actually
installing python so now that so I will
show you how to install python on
Windows since I have a Windows system
however I will also point out the way
you you would have to install python on
a on Mac OS or Linux or even on mobile
so yeah let's get started so to install
python on your Windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the download
section when you reduce click on
downloads you get redirected to this
website that this webpage that I'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well by just scrolling
down and choosing the option that you
want now it's important to note that
whatever option you choose of course I
would recommend the latest one but no
matter what option you choose I would
recommend you choose a version of python
three point something because previous
versions of python namely Python 2.7 and
uh and basically every version of python
2. something has it will not receive any
more maintenance and updates because the
developers have decided that python will
that trying to shift towards the
maintaining and updating python three
point whatever completely right now so
yeah let's not delay this uh any further
and let's download python 3.9 so once
you select the option out here uh you'll
be you'll get an installer all you have
to do is click on that and it'll give
you two options to customize
installation or install now I would of
course recommend this blue install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into the drive where your windows is
actually installed your your main drive
so as you can see now that once my setup
is done it should give me a pop-up soon
so my setup is done for Python and this
is essentially how you would
um download python on your Windows
system but what if you had Mac OS or if
you were using Linux well for Mac it's a
it's actually almost as simple you just
go if you see our here below this
download button python option you get
the website asking you are you looking
for python on a different OS and it
gives you the options of Linux Mac and
even other os's but for Mac if you
wanted you would just open this tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if I
wanted say python the latest one I would
just download this installer and I would
install in my Mac system now when it
comes to Linux I cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
would just choose the Linux option out
here it would take you to a page with a
different installers and essentially
packages for Linux systems in specific
what I would recommend to you if you are
a Linux user and you need python is to
go over to the realpython.com website
and they have a very good essentially
instructions on how to install Python
and since I don't have a Linux system
them I cannot directly show you how to
install python on Linux so yeah if you
do have Linux please head over to this
website and this should be of a lot of
help to you now as I had mentioned you
can actually install python on your
mobile devices as well so if you were
say an iOS user you would go to the iOS
App Store and download an app called the
python is the app for iOS it essentially
is like a full-fledged python
environment where you can develop in
Python on your iPhone or even iPad and
if you're an Android User you could you
would go and download an app called the
pi Droid 3. there's a free version and a
paid version for this app and of course
the difference between the free and paid
is that the paid supports uh code
analysis and code prediction these are
certain details you don't have to worry
about right now and honestly if I
wouldn't worry too much about installing
python on your mobile devices currently
since I am assuming most people would be
learning Pro programming and programming
in Python on their PCS or laptops what I
had actually shown you was installing
what is called an implementation of
python on your system and implementation
is essentially a program or a software
or an environment that allows you to
actually work in Python so what I showed
you was how to install the by default or
the most basic or reference
implementation that has been created by
the developers which is actually called
C python even though you would not you
would not have seen the word the letter
c or the prefix C but yeah that
implementation that I had I had
downloaded myself and I had shown you to
download is actually the C python
implementation which is python built on
top of C the the C language essentially
there are other implementations such as
iron python which uses the.net framework
and J python that uses Java virtual
machines that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that I would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python I want to introduce what is
called a distribution to you this
distribution is called Anaconda Anaconda
is a very important distribution
especially if you are looking to use
python in data science and machine
learning and AI which I am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards moving
towards data science and if that is your
goal or in any case whatever your goal
may be I would recommend that you
install Anaconda distribution now do not
get confused between anaconda and python
their Anaconda is python with in the
form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that I had shown you to
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and Technologies and software
as well so of course this means that
what you need to download both of course
not if you download a python you do not
need Anaconda to work on Python and if
you have already downloaded Anaconda
which I will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
Anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so I'll just speak
about Anaconda a little briefly so as I
said it's a distribution it it contains
a bundle which includes the basic python
implementation and a lot of Technologies
and softwares and applications that have
essentially help us to use python in in
in specifically managing Big Data
applications and data science related
projects so so now I will show you
actually how to install python I mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if I did
a quick quick Google Anaconda
so the website that I'm looking for is
anaconda.com and I'm looking at products
and I'm looking at individual Edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial Team edition these are for
companies usually or uh for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
Edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to this particular
web page where It'll ask you if you want
to download and again there are options
depending on which machine you're using
if you're using a Linux you would choose
one of these two if you are using Mac OS
you would use one of these two and since
I am a Windows user and I have a 64-bit
system this is the option I would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been downloaded so upon
opening it it will open up this
installation thing and you can just
click next on most of these again if you
want to specify your destination folder
you can change it here mine will be with
a default folder in the C drive and you
can leave this unticked you can you can
change these options much later so this
is how you install an account on Windows
and it's pretty much the same on other
systems as well now once it's done I
will show you what exactly what are some
of the things that Anaconda contains
that are not there if you installed
python like the way I had shown you
earlier just the bare bones python
implementation so as you can see here my
installation is actually complete and
now I will open anaconda and I'll show
you what how you can actually use this
Anaconda so if I search for anaconda in
my system I would look for something
called Anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when I open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the Anaconda Navigator and as you can
see there are a bunch of applications
you don't need to worry about what these
mean right now just understand that this
this is essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install Anaconda Navigator now now
that we have actually tackled where
we've seen how to install and I'm hoping
and I would recommend definitely that
everyone is watching this video installs
Anaconda not just the normal python
installation or implementation now that
we have gotten all the introductions in
the basics and the installations
regarding python aside let's get right
let's get down to actually creating our
first script so now the question is how
do we actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we how do we realize uh now that we've
installed uh python like uh now let's
how do we start doing something so the
answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic thing that you
can do is create a python script and
execute a script script is essentially a
sequence of commands and instructions
that you give for python to run and
execute to give you a certain result so
I will show you how you can create a
python script now there are multiple
ways of creating a python script you can
create it directly from command line
which is obviously something I would not
recommend because it is not convenient
and easy and it's not very useful for a
beginner another way is using a text
editor such as the one I have opened
right now which is the notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused between notepad plus
plus and the standard notepad that comes
with your windows or wordpad for that
matter in fact text editors such as
notepad and wordpad that you are more
familiar with create text and files in a
form that is called Rich Text Now Rich
Text is something is text that contains
format setting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text plain
text is obviously text which does not
contain these fonts and these
formattings and it only respects white
spaces and indentations those two being
actually useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents that is very that
was actually created with programming in
mind obviously you can use a bunch of
other text editors such as vim and atom
and you can Google for these there are
plenty of them so without any further
Ado let's create our first python script
so one of the most common one of the
most famous examples of it a first
program in any program for that matter
not just python is creating a print
statement that gives us a statement
saying hello world so enter in Python
this is how you would go about oh this
is the syntax you would use to create
the statement all right now weight is
very important when you are saving your
Python program that you use the dot py
prefix so so if I were to save this I
can choose whatever folder I am going to
choose yeah this folder seems fine so
now I give the file name over here as
say I want to keep it as test I need to
prefix this Dot py and this tells any uh
sort of interpreter or anytime we need
to read the script to know that it's a
python script we need to add a DOT py
otherwise it will not be treated as a
python script it'll be treated as some
normal document sort of a thing so now
that I have stored it as dot py I have
created my first python script now
obviously the next question is I need to
see what happens when I execute this
line when I run this script essentially
so to see that there are multiple ways
the first way that I will show you is a
command line method which is obviously 3
again before we get into it it's not
something that I will be using to teach
you it's not something I would recommend
you to immediately start using
um but for the sake of showing I will
show you how to execute a script in
command line well to do this you go
since I have installed anaconda in my
system and I will be using Anaconda to
work in Python what I will look for is
something called the Anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that I
get Anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this now I am already in
the folder I believe that had my script
so how do I call this script or how do I
run this script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so I enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders in command
line which is again something that I
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that I am in in
my command line I would just have to
enter this Command right now so if I
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what I wanted I wanted it to
print this uh these two words and of
course the command line is now waiting
for the next command for me so this is
uh one of the most simple ways for the
most rudimentary ways of executing a
python script now another question would
be well this isn't the most visually
appealing or not the easy to read or
easy to use way of executing scripts and
I would agree and that's why I'm going
to introduce a another technology or a
software called the IDE so the IDE in
python or in any programming language
stands for integrated development
environment it's essentially a software
that not only allows us to run scripts
but it allows us to create the scripts
it allows us to debug it allows us to
see outputs it allows us to the
intermediary outputs it allows us to do
a wide variety of tools and tasks and it
comes with a bunch of robust features to
enhance our Python programming
experience so let's let's see so I will
show you a an IDE called spider which
comes bundled along with the Anaconda
distribution that I had mentioned
earlier so if I open the Anaconda
Navigator as you can see the Anaconda
Navigator shows me a bunch of
Technologies and options and I'm looking
for something called the spider IDE
which is over here as you see here it's
a Scientific Python development
environment this is exactly what I'm
looking for so I am looking to launch
this so now that I've launched it you
can see out here this is what an IDE
looks like now this looks very
sophisticated and it's a it's a one and
any almost any IDE is a wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider ID in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
common solar console essentially
so now that we have we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and I want to open that script and I
want to see uh how an i how it would the
result of that script would look in an
IDE so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as I had named
it test this is the file over here I
open this and as you can see out here in
the left hand pane my script has opened
and the commander had given or had
written is out over here now if I want
to run this application I press this
green button and as you can see the
result of my my execution essentially is
over here it's in slightly small font
but as you can see over here it says
hello world and its way and the next
line is essentially it's it's waiting
for me to do another execution of the
script and then it will give me new
results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that I have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say I will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what I'm exactly doing these things that
we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
number three let's create a variable B
Story number five all right let's create
another variable C uh which will store
the result of what's in a and b in the
addition of A and B all right and let's
print the result or print what's in uh
this variable C or what's the result of
a plus b I will print a statement saying
the result of the addition of three and
five is all right and I will put my
result over here as you can see I should
get the result in this pane so let's
execute this and you can see uh my first
line is executed saying I will perform
basic maths and the next line says the
result of the addition of three and five
is eight so this in this script what
I've done is I have performed uh two
print statements and I performed a basic
expression some variable assignments all
of these things we will be doing later
this is what I what I'm essentially
trying to show you is that Ides are a
very convenient way of not only creating
the scripts but actually seeing the
results and then making adjustments as
well we can come we can create a
completely new script we don't need to
create a script from some special file
or text editor I can just create a new
file here and this is my new script
essentially so I can start working on
with this new script right over here
from the get go so Ides are very
powerful spider IDE comes bundled with
Anaconda there are other ideas such as
the idle IDE it stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle IDE comes as
part of the basic python implementation
that I had shown you in the previous
video where you if you just installed a
basic uh python implementation it would
come along with a basic IDE known as
Idle or integrated development and
learning environment but of course since
we are using Python and this is what I
would recommend it comes with a more
robust IDE called spider which is
actually very very helpful for
scientific and numeric applications and
was designed specifically with that in
mind now this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and a very
educative method of it in Python let's
say python programs and it's something
that I will be using extensively
throughout this course to explain
different concepts so this technology is
called or the software is called uh
notebooks now before I get into the
details I will state I will just open
node a basic notebook so the notebook
that comes as part of anaconda is called
the Jupiter notebook and when I open
when I launch the Jupiter notebook this
is what I get now a very important
feature or a a feature of notebooks is
that notebooks are a web browser or a
web-based application so you it's not
something that you can use if you are
offline or disconnected basically if
you're disconnected from the internet it
is something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good properties that allow it
to be used in education or for
presentation and such so as you can see
this is my Jupiter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now I will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here now you go to new and
you select under notebook the Python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that I
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed the diff in uh
until now everything that we were doing
involved us creating a script which was
the whole series of commands and
functions so if I go back to my spider
IDE as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different tasks and functions that are
individually being performed so this is
a separate print function this is a
separate Edition another separated print
function and for longer programs or
larger program terms you like you'll
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like uh what
is the result of just this print
statement or just this uh it's not
typically what an IDE is used for and
this is where notebooks come in super
handy if I had to break down my previous
script essentially where I first did a
print statement where I said some random
thing say hello
yeah so if I execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now I want to do what is 5 plus 3 it
should give me the result over here
eight now in the next another part of
your program might be storing five and
three into variables so I can do this
and I can do this so now this line will
store the variables now I want to do the
addition of what is five plus three but
I want to use the variables and I want
to see what's the result as you can see
a plus b means 5 plus 3 which is 8 and
I've essentially broken down various
different parts of my previous script
into into its individual tasks and I'm
able to see what each part of that
script does and this is very good when
it comes to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so I will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
um different concepts when it comes to
Python and I would recommend that you
get used to notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to Learn Python
Programming or programming in general in
fact and again as I had mentioned
earlier notebooks are something that
it's an online application it's a
web-based application so I will have to
need a active internet connection to be
able to work on a notebook which could
be a disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
Ides or text editor which you can be
used offline as well in this video we
will be introduced to the concept of
variables and expressions let's start
with Expressions well an expression in
Python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in Python is that a
statement in Python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as I said
audio calculation resulting in between
two different say numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if I were to add two numbers
say 5 plus 10 this is an expression
which should where two objects 5 and 10
are being added and a result has been
given to me which is 15. now let's see
an example of a statement well a
statement could be something like a
print statement so when I ask python to
print something for me it's not
calculating anything it's not evaluating
anything it's simply performing an
action that I have or a command that I
have given the system which is to print
whatever I have entered over here as you
can see so this is a statement similarly
there are another type of statement
known as assignment statements which we
will learn actually right in the next
section well let's move on to variables
right now now earlier you might have
learned about objects in Python so
objects are essentially data that we can
work with a manipulate in Python now
variables are a place to store these
different objects
usually it's much easier to store
objects in Python instead of using the
objects explicitly themselves because
objects may be very compute complicated
whereas variables are very simple to use
and very simply very named in a very
simple manner so that we can use them
quite often in our programs now it's
important to note that in Python we do
not have to explicitly declare or Define
a variable to create them in fact
variables are created in the same
statement where we assign some object to
the variable in Python the assignment of
variables happens using the assignment
operator which is the equals design so
if I were to if I wanted to assign a
number say 100 to a variable say B well
it would be as simple as doing this now
anytime I want to know what is stored in
B I just have to enter B and I will get
the value that is stored in it and we
can store different types of objects
inside any variable let's say I store I
want to store this particular word in
the form of a string now this is stored
in X and if I want to know what is an X
I can just see what is here and it's a
string hello which I had stored earlier
now it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown error so we might get
some problems in our program
so the first rule is that you cannot
start your variable name with a number
so if I were to give a variable name
like 4 num is equal to something say the
same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and I would get an
error when I try this so if I were to
choose a num 4 is equal to hello this
would be perfectly fine I won't get an
error the second rule is we are not
allowed to use any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if I were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and I
stay I said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if I
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if if I have a variable called num or
say n-u-m if this was one of my
variables and I stored say the value 50.
this is not the same as me writing num
all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in Python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call Reserve words in Python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are user identifiers for
certain special functions in Python that
we that have a special purpose like that
particular word has a special purpose
within the Python programming language
and you cannot use them to name our
variables so a list of them as you can
see over here some of them are like
false def if Del Rays and there are like
are there are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept uh where we try to
really understand what do we mean by
storing data inside a variable now when
I say that we are storing something
inside a variable you get an image or
you get an idea in your head that this
variable is like a container where we
store or we put a particular object
inside it so does this mean that
variables have a place in the memory are
they are also an object that is placed
in the memory where we can put other
objects inside of well I'll show you an
example where this idea is kind of
disproven or where I'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say I'm storing the same object I
will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and I'm going to
store it into two different variables so
I take X is equal to 100 over here and
in the next line I will store 100 in y
as well now if objects were I mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then X and Y should have two
different IDs but let's see what happens
when I check the ID of X and the ID of Y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the ID of X and the ID of
Y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
Python cannot have the same ID so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in Python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
I said X is equal to 100 and Y is equal
to 100 what I am actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called X that I want to refer or
Point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and I do the
same thing with another other variable y
so I am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when I do ID of X and ID of 5
it's not giving me the idea of something
called X or the ID of something called Y
is giving me the ID of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in X and Y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what I'm trying
to say and similarly if if I were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see I've used the value of 50 to explain
my point so as you can see initially X
and Y are pointing towards this value 50
because I have stored 50 and 50 in both
X and Y now what if I changed the object
that is stored in X well that means X is
now pointing towards this new object and
I have stored this new object called
hello the string called hello as you can
see here so now X is pointing to a new
object in the system and it's called
hello and I haven't changed anything
with respect to Y so y will Point
towards the same thing and I can also
make the pointer of Y different or what
I'm trying to say is I can store
something else in y see I stored this
list in my 50 60 100 and when I do that
now Y is pointing towards a different
object in Python and X is also pointing
towards something else so what happens
to this object 50 well now that there's
no variable referring to this object 50
it becomes what we call an orphaned
object and we can actually see that when
we do the ID of X now let's go back to
my example on the right where I stored X
is equal to 100 so as you can see it
gives me some ID represented by this
number now let's say I stored x i stored
something different say 200 now if I do
the ID of X it should give me a
different ID because as you can see the
values are different and this is because
this object 200 is what is stored in X
and when I do the ID of X I'm actually
getting the ID of this new object now
200 so as you can see Point as you can
see variables are they should be and
they are treated more like references or
pointers instead of containers for a
particular object in this video you will
be introduced to the concept of objects
in Python now what are objects in Python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
the usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually stored in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the Boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
and we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in Python has three
important properties that kind of Define
that particular object they are its
ident entity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one at once it has been
created so for example if I took an
example of say a string called hello I
can use the ID function which is this is
how you use the ID function to find out
the ID of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the ID of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in Python have an identity we
have another operation with regarding
the identity of an object it's the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially what
defines what kind of values and
operations that that object can have so
for example in numeric data type in
Python such as an integer would allow us
to do arithmetic operations and
similarly string object type in Python
will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that I had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string Str stands for string similarly
if I did a type for a number say 50 it
should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
Python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if I were to talk about this
string this string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation I have shown you that you
can assume this dodge Blue Area as the
memory of the system now within this
memory we have objects created called 50
and hello and this list containing
smaller objects called cat pen and 40.
now what I'm trying to show you here is
each of these objects have a type an ID
and a value and let's see what they are
if I wanted to see as we had already
seen the type of 50 now let's find the
ID of 50 as you can see we get this
unique ID for the object 50 which is
obviously not the same as the ID of the
object hello above and the value of this
object is the value as 50 itself so that
was a brief and introduction into
objects in Python in this video we will
cover the topics of numeric object types
and type conversions in Python now let's
get started numeric object types in
Python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in Python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in Python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
Python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent new builds that contain
decimal points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8
minus 6.8 and so on then there is the
complex object type which is used to
represent complex numbers in Python and
this is an example of a complex number 3
plus 7j okay this is a complex number
three plus seven J where the real
component is 3 and the imaginary
component is 7. all complex numbers have
a real and an imaginary component and
this is how we denote them now it's
important to note that this J is a very
common symbol in maths and Engineering
used to denote the imaginary portion of
a complex number and it's the same in
python as well so moving on let's talk
about type conversion in Python type
conversion refers to the conversion of
an object from one data type to another
for example from string to an integer
and there are different types of
conversions and let's go through some of
them first of all let's consider the
conversion of something to an integer
and more specifically let's consider the
example where we convert a string to an
integer so let's consider my example
string to be some something called 145
and I'm sewing this within a string for
a reason because I want to convert is
string to an integer so as you can see I
have stored this one for 5 within my
within a variable X and if I were to
confirm that is actually an integer I
can use the type function and see that
it is actually an integer Str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the int Sim by passing
the variable that we want to convert
into the int function and as you can see
this is what I've done over here but
before this I will also store it into
another variable all right now let's see
what's in y well y gives us 145 but are
we sure that it's an end we can just
check it by using the type function and
as you can see the type gives us the
answer end that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and also specify what base we have to
treat the number as by default when we
pass something in the in function the
program or python will treat whatever we
have passed within the string as
something in base sub decimal but what
if we were to pass something that is
well not in a decimal we could do it
like this now let's store Y and in y
let's store
let's do this and I will show you what
this means X and I will give a comma and
eight what this tells python is well I
want to convert the string in X into an
integer but I want to treat whatever is
an X as a number of Base 8 so 145 is
actually 145 and the base 8 now when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 1 0 1 is
actually the decimal equivalent of 145
in the base 8. similarly if we were to
give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if I give
120 and I pass this integer through the
float function I should get 120.0 and
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and 1.120.0
is a different object which is a float
and this is how we convert something to
a float now what if we wanted to convert
an integer to a string well we can use
the Str function we can also use the hex
and the op function if we want to
convert a particular number to a
hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say I have a number 688 and I
want to convert this into a string I
just use the Str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is this
should be an end as we can see but when
we pass when we let's say we convert it
into a string 688 and let's store it
into some variable let's call it a all
right now let's see what's in a it gives
us 688 in the form of a string but we
can confirm by checking the type of a it
is an Str so it is a string similarly we
can use hex if we wanted to convert an
integer into its hexadecimal equivalent
in the in in as an output of a string as
you can see this complex is sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero should not be treated
as anything it's more like a an
identifier which says that the letter
after this first 0 is the base of this
whole number so it's saying that x x
stands for hexadecimal so it's saying
that 2 B 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688 similarly if I
did opt if I use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first 0 is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this 0 is the base of the
number following these two following
these two characters so as you can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an OCT
represented by this letter O and the
number itself that we are dealing with
is one two six zero and one two six zero
in octal system is the equivalent of 688
in the decimal system so this is how
we've converted a an integer in an
integer into a hexadecimal or a an octal
string now what if we wanted to convert
two numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if I passed complex 5 and say say
something like 3.1 let's see what this
gives us as you can see it gives us an a
complex object where our real part is 5
and our imaginary part is 3.1 so what
this does is essentially you pass two
numbers the first one is the real
component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if I
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
I will use the Tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say I have a
string called random let's call it
random all right now if I want to
convert this to a tuple I will use the
Tuple function as you can see over here
the output will give me tuples where
each individual component end of this
Tuple are the individual components or
the individual characters of my string
random similarly if I wanted to convert
the string to a list I would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters of the
word or the string random and I could do
the same thing with the set function to
create a set of individual characters of
the string random as you can see here so
yeah these were some of the basic python
type conversions that I have shown you
as we learn about more complex data
types and different object types in
Python we will learn different type
conversions and functions associated
with them in this video you will be
introduced to the concept of strings
strings are an object type in Python
used to store textual data this textual
data could be something like for example
someone's name it could be an address of
a place or it could be something like a
word or a sentence now strings in Python
are an object type that is actually a
subtype of a broader classification of
objects called sequences sequences are
objects in Python which contain
components placed one of the other where
each component is given what we call an
index a numeric Index this numeric index
identifies the component in the sequence
and is position within the sequence now
since python is a zero index based
language the first object of any
sequence is always index 0 the second is
index 1 the third is index 2 and so on
now let's move on to defining strings
how do we Define them well strings are
defined using what we call delimiters
and delimiters occur in pairs in opening
and a closing delimiter in Python these
zerometers are pairs of single or double
quotes so for example if I were to use
single quotes to define a string I could
I would do it like this it's a string as
you can see this is a string is printed
over here this is delimited using single
quotes similarly if I were to define a
string using double quotes it's as
simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see now a valid question
arises what if I wanted to include a
single quote within my string well if I
try to let's see what happens if I try
to print a statement with a single quote
naturally inside it so say I'm saying
it's my birthday all right let's see
what happens if I try to print this
statement it says invalid syntax and
this is because as I had mentioned in
Python single quotes and double quotes
are delimiters so they have a special
function in Python and we cannot simply
just use them within a string because
python will treat them specially for a
special purpose so what python will do
is it will pair this and this delimiter
so single quotes and say okay this looks
like a string to me and it's not going
to understand the rest of this and then
it will find a random single quote and
it won't find its pair and it will
basically throw us an error because of
this so one way or one word around to
introduce single quotes into a string is
simply to delimit our string itself
using the other type of delimiter or
double quotes So if I want to include a
single code I will close my string using
double quotes So if I did this instead
of what I had done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and I could I
would do the opposite if I had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string I would use single quotes to
close it so if I were to write a speech
statement she said
I am
hungry all right I have I want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and I'm gonna close the
string using single quotes and this is a
valid way of doing it as you can see my
string has this two double quotes now I
had mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how other sequences
so first of all all sequences in Python
are a
um it's a essentially a sequence of
smaller objects that form the sequence
right so let's try to understand like
how do how are strings to be treated as
sequences some sequences that we will
learn later are like lists or tuples and
in all sequences we can retrieve any
particular object or component in that
sequence using its index and how do we
use indexes in Python well we enclose a
numeric index within square brackets now
let's see what I'm trying to talk about
by this example now say I'm storing a
particular string called say random
within so now my variable name here is
test and I'm storing the string random
within it all right and this is the way
of retrieving a particular index from
test I write the variable name and then
next to it I put the square brackets now
I'm supposed to put a numeral within the
square brackets to tell python like what
a particular index I'm looking for so
let's try 0. now as I said python is
zero index based language so the zero
index essentially means the first part
of or the first component of a sequence
so let's see what happens when I ask
python to retrieve the first part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string R in fact it's just one character
R and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is R so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
Random is essentially a collection of
the string R the string a the string n
and so on together combined to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if I wanted the character at
the third position of this thing I would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in Python I would
use the index too and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's given
me the letter N so this is how we can
show that strings are also sequences in
Python well now let's move on to certain
string operations and functions that we
can perform well as you have seen
already that we can retrieve any
particular character within a within a
string using numeric indexes well what
if we wanted to know what index is a
particular character at and we can do it
like this we use the index function so
let's say my test and I want to know
where where or what position the
character D is in my string random so
this is how I would use the index
function index and within the index say
I'm looking for the character D and now
I it should give me the answer 0 1 2 it
should give me the answer three so if I
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is uh the index function that we
can use for our strings now what if we
want to
um say slice a string into a into its uh
into a smaller part you want to slice it
and we want to retrieve only that
particular size well here is an example
say I'm gonna I'm gonna use the same
string called random and stored in test
right so let's
so one way of so the way of doing this
is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if I went to my
string random A and D is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what I
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice from the first position uh the
first index which is the character a up
until the fourth position which is the
character o but it has not included o so
it's very important when I index like
this every every time I put something to
the right of this colon I am not
including this itself all right so it's
essentially one when I say one colon
four what I'm telling python is give me
the first the second and the third
character but not the fourth one so it's
given me a n and d and it's that's this
is how we do a slicing operation in
Python similarly if I were to say slice
from the first if I wanted only first
and the second character I would do this
is what I would do if I wanted the first
and the second character I would do one
two three so this way it sets python
that I want the first I want the second
but not the third off so as you can see
I get a and N now so this is a basic
slicing what if I wanted the portion of
a string from a particular Point all the
way to the right or all the way to the
left well let's consider the example of
where I want the portion of the string
random from the say fourth character
until the left well the way I would do
this is test now since I want it all the
way to the left I don't enter any index
to the left of my colon sign and since I
want everything to the left of the
fourth character I enter 4 here so as
you can see it gives me A R A and D
which is everything from the fourth
character of my string random to the
left similarly if I wanted something to
the right of it I would just do it like
this I would enter some index here and I
I would leave the portion to the right
of the colon blank so this will give me
everything including the third character
since this is how we treat the indexing
in Python everything including the third
character all the way to the right so
this is Dom as you can see now another
perfectly valid um slicing is say I want
to slice or take out different
characters from the string but I want to
skip certain characters like I want this
one then I want to skip one and I want
to take the next one and then I want to
skip one well in that case we have to
introduce a step so one way of doing
this is now how do we read this so as
you can see I've written 0 colon six
colon two so what this is telling python
is I want every character from my string
test starting from the zeroth character
up until the sixth but not including the
sixth after skipping or taking two at a
time taking two at a time can also be
assumed as uh skipping one at each step
or skipping one character at each step
so what this will do is it will go to
random it will take the zeroth one we'll
take R and then it will skip the next
one so it will not consider a and then
it will pick n and then it will not
consider D and then it will consider o
up until the sixth character whichever
that whichever that may be and if you
see the output it gives us R and O which
is exactly what we wanted we wanted R we
wanted n we wanted o where we skipped uh
A and D or we skipped the every second
character essentially so this is a way
of
um slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in Python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if I were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is the minus one index it
gives me the character M now remember a
string Is Random so minus 1 gave us the
last character of the string random
which was m so this is a way of using
negative indexes and similarly if I used
to test minus 2 it would give me the
second last character which should be
the character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in Python for that
let's create another let's create
another string let's call it upper lower
all right I'm sorting it again in the
same variable test let's see what
happens when I use the upper function
and what happens when I use the lower
function
now I'm going to use the lower function
for this so these two functions will
respectively give out or give us the
result or give us our string in
uppercase and lowercase respectively so
as you can see the upper function
created the first string in full upper
case and the second one created this by
the string in four lower case now
another important and probably one of
the most important methods that we use
for Strings especially when it comes to
data science is the split function so
let's see what I mean by split function
let me create another string let's call
it hello world
all right I'm going to use a split
function and I'm going to see what
happens when I use this function
essentially so what I'm doing in these
in this these three lines is I'm
creating the string hello world I am
storing it in test and then I am using
the split function on the test and
whatever result I get I'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
I'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that I have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and I stored both
of these into what we call a list now
you might ask well how does python know
that it has to separate at a blank space
well the split function by default will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or at every comma so for example
if I wrote hello world using comma and
if I put a comma inside over here and
now if I try to execute this
like for example I am going to find I'm
going to look for commas in the string
and I'm gonna try to split it as you can
see there's no splitting happening I
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if I introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and is caused a split
between hello and World similarly if I
in my string if I put this comma again
and I put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
Define our split using some whatever we
put between these Circle brackets after
the split function it's just important
to note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting uh
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if I have two
strings first and say another string
second and I want to join these together
well the operator I would use to do this
is called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
Strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing and let's see
what is the result as you can see what
uh this has done is it has combined the
first string first and the string second
into one string called first second so
this is the concatenated concatenation
operator now finally uh the last Topic
in this lesson is the topic of Escape
sequences now Escape sequences are
special commands that tell python to
either suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character in a string so let's look at
the first example now remember my in my
for earlier in this video where I was I
was telling you like what what is the
way of writing or how do we introduce
single quotes or double quotes into a
string and I had told you the trick if I
want to use single coat in my string I
just close it using double quotes or if
I want to use a double quote I close it
using single well another way of doing
this is using what we call an escape
sequence and an escape sequence in
Python is the backslash character all
right so let's see what happens when I
use the backslash character where I want
to introduce my single code so if I use
my previous example where I wanted to
introduce a single quote and say I am
going to close it using single quotes as
well so I'm gonna go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error at as you can see it
has thrown me an error so what if I used
the escape sequence that I mentioned the
Escape sequences is backslash character
now this is the point of the string
where I want my my single code so I
introduce a backslash now I have my
single quote and I continue writing the
rest of my statement let's close the
string now will this work as you can see
this has worked so what this has done is
this backside character store python do
not trade this special character or the
single quote to not treat it specially
and let it be as a part of the string so
as you can see that's what's happened
here now the next case or the other use
case of Escape sequences is when we want
to give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so let's take the example of the
character T and the character n we use
the character T to introduce tab space
and Views a character in to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
T has no special function so the
character T within a string will just be
outputted as the character T itself
however as you can see here I'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t let's see what it does it
introduces this thing that we called a
tab space which is a larger than normal
space similarly if I were to use the
backslash n combination this would
introduce what we call a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where I have this combination of
backslash m a line break has occurred so
there are plenty of other Escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and uh these are just two of the
probably the most common ones that are
used in this video I will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what a sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we Define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way or a
simple list that I have just created and
assigned to a variable a which contains
three objects one two and three let's
talk about some of the features of
python lists python lists are ordered
and what this means is that even if two
lists contain the exact same elements if
they if the elements are placed in a
different order the two lists are
actually unique and different and I can
check that over here I have created a
list one two and three and say if I
create another list two and one and
three the same elements were in
different order I will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when I use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they're not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see I
get the value false because even though
I have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where I
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are Dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making our as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are programming without having to go
through a compilation stage so if we had
to say increase the or we had to add
certain elements to an already created
list that original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if I created a
list right now where say if I want to
store some numbers
say some floating Point numbers now and
I can put strings as well into my list
all of these are valid uh when it comes
to objects that can be put inside a list
we have no such restrictions so we can
put any arbitrary objects inside our
list the final property that I want to
talk about is that lists are they can be
nested to any arbitrary depth what this
means is that I can put a list within a
list and I can keep nesting it
essentially by putting as many lists I
want within my list and I'm only
essentially restricted by my systems
memory so if I created a list like this
within this say I put any other list and
within this list I put another list I
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and I'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that I'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where I'm storing six numbers
so now say if I want to retrieve a
particular element say if I want to find
out what's on the index 3 this is how I
would do it if I wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings I do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that I want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it will
give me one two and three index objects
so it should give me 2 3 and 4 in this
case as you can see here 2 3 and 4. I
can do the same thing by considering
elements say two at a time if I wanted
to consider elements or consider every
second element what I would do is this
syntax I would use this syntax and when
I give this command to python what it
tells what it understands is I want
every element from a from index 1 to
index 4 but not including index 4 but I
am going to consider considered to every
second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then Skip One
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call
slicing by using strides so I'm taking
strides I'm not considering elements
consecutively but I'm skipping certain
elements in between if I wanted to
consider every third element I would
change this to three and fourth element
I would change this to Fourth all right
so let's see what happens when I take
every second element it should give it
should give me uh it will consider say
from one to index three right so you
should consider essentially this section
but since it's going to skip one it's
going to consider this skip this and
then consider this it should give me two
and four as you can see it has given me
two and four and like in other sequences
we can use negative indexes as well
negative indexing essentially starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when I say A minus y one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
the object six if I did a minus two it
gives me the second last element
similarly another neat trick that we can
use for sequences is the following
syntax double colon and we give a minus
one what this tells the what this tells
the system is I want the list a but with
all the elements reversed so as you can
see I get my element uh my list a but
the elements have been reversed right
now let's move on to uh concatenation
and replication well concatenation much
like in strings is done by using the
plus sign so as we know on either side
of the plus sign should be two similar
objects so if I'm doing a plus something
a being a list on the other side it
should be a list as well so let's add a
list like this now let's see what's in a
as you can see my origin list has a 789
added to it and I can also add things to
the beginning of a list similarly so if
I wanted to add say zero you know at the
beginning for this I just do it like
this
and I get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that I I actually
added 0 within a list because if I did 0
like this
it will throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an end object and it's
not a list but when I put the square
brackets I make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if I did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where I'm repeating
the values in a twice if I did a star
three it's the same function but now
I'll have the elements repeated Thrice
as you can see here let's move on to
modifying list values uh this also shows
the mutable property of lists that I had
mentioned earlier so let's consider this
example so I created a list with
elements where it is the three strings
eggs apples and carrots and I have five
int objects one two three four and five
now if I wanted to change say the first
element all I have to do is take the 0th
index and say if I want to replace eggs
with same mango this is how I would do
it now replace eggs with mango if I
check what's in B you can see the eggs
have been replaced with the element
mango similarly I can use the slice
syntax to replace a particular slice
from my list with a slice essentially so
let's look at this I'm replacing I want
to replace the first three elements I
want to replace mango I want to replace
apple and carrot so what I will do is I
will consider this since this carrot is
the second index so I will consider 0 to
3 because the third is not counted now
I'm going to replace this with three
different
um let's see kiwi
and it's a sponge now let's check what's
in B you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact I don't have to
replace like for like if I want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if I want to replace the first three
elements give you orange and sponge
with
um just one element this is how I'll do
it let's say
wine now let's check what's here as you
can see three elements have been
replaced with one mine I can double vice
versa as well I can replace smaller
number of elements with a larger number
of elements but here there is a slight
caveat that I want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if I wanted to replace the first element
wine with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index and then put whatever
objects you want say I want to add
instead of wine I want to add beer I
want to add ball and say Club yeah well
let's see what happens now if I say B
check what's inside my you can see my
elements have been added but they seem
to have been added as is you know I had
entered a list over here and that whole
list has been replaced uh or this wine
has been replaced by this whole list in
the first position but that's not
exactly what I want wanted I wanted the
elements within this list to be
individually placed into my list and the
way to do that is not this syntax but
actually what I'm going to show you now
if I want to replace one if I want to
replace the index of the object at index
0 I would give this statement a slice
statement where I will give 0 colon 1 so
when I do this and if I
um so let's create my old scenario again
where I had wine and I had one two three
four and five now if I do this B 0 but I
give a slice then this slice is
essentially a single object slice it's
essentially the zeroth index again but
because of this formatting or this this
type of syntax that I'm using what
python will do is now when I say peer
and ball and club now what python will
do is it will not consider this whole
list and add it to in place of uh wine
or whatever I want to replace it will
actually consider the elements inside of
this individually and then replace so if
you see here now if you see my list I
actually have the I've removed wine and
in place of it I've put beer ball in
club but these three are actually
individual objects within my list and
not objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods Associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first operation that I
want to show you or the first method is
the append method so I do a append and
say if I want to append the list by one
object called four I just do it like
this now let's see what's in a I put so
as you can see the append has put the
object 4 into my original list now say
if I wanted to append three different
objects I want to append five six and
seven now let's see what append function
does oh no as you can see it's done a
similar operation to what we have seen
earlier when we gave a single index or
the single element replacement uh that
we saw earlier it essentially put this
whole list into this particular spot
into the list and this is not what I
wanted I wanted five six and seven to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what I'll
show you next now if I want to extend
Say the original list by three different
elements eight nine ten when I use the
extend function it will not put this
whole thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what I wanted now the next
method that I want to discuss is the
remove method so the remove method is
what you how you use it is within the
parenthesis you put the object that is
present in the list that you want to
removed so you don't give an index over
here you give the object itself so if I
want the object eight all right this
number if I want 8 itself removed what I
will do is put the value 8 here and it
will remove it from my list so if I
check my list a as you can see the value
8 has it's gone an X another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the rightmost value from the list
but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value and that value
is what we have popped out of the list
so by default it will pop out the right
route right most value of a list a
rightmost element of a list and in this
case that element is 10 so it should
give me 10 but of course if we want to
pop out any particular object in this
case we will not give that particular
object we give its index so now say if I
want to remove this uh this list object
from my bigger list
um as I can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4.
it's the fourth index so if I want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index I give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for list let's move on to tuples next so
tuples are another ordered collection of
objects much like lists but they differ
from lists in two Key Properties first
of all the tuples are defined using
parenthesis instead of square brackets
so this is how I would Define a tuple
with elements one two and three and the
next very important property that is
different or that differentiates tuples
from lists is that tuples are immutable
and what this means is that once we
create an object of type Tuple we cannot
make any modifications to it we would
have to only create create a new object
if we wanted something different and
this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this every operation that we have
done on lists are actually possible to
do in the case of tuples as well so any
operation that we did to lists that did
not modify the list or that does not do
any modification we can actually apply
to tuples as well so if I wanted the
first element of this difficult all I
have to do is call it by the index 0 it
should give me the value 1 as you can
see if I wanted a slice I can do that as
well it should give me 2 and 3 and if I
wanted to reverse my Tuple well I can
use my same neat technique that I've
used for lists and that I can use for
the sequence I mean strings as well so
it gives me my old Tuple but with the
elements reversed so now the natural
question is why do we use Tuple server
lists well one important difference is
that when we can when we make a program
execution where or where we are
manipulating a tuple if we did the same
thing for the exact same objects in uh
that if it were present in a list it
would be much faster in a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so use tuples over list
when we want to be efficient while we
are creating an ordered list of objects
so whenever we create an ordered list of
objects that we don't need to or we
don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in Python that
needs an immutable component while we
are creating the dictionary so if we
want to use uh something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what what I mean by the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuples
over a list uh a brief section on Tuple
unpacking and packing is what I would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when I create when I give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be me packing
this Tuple into a object or a
variability now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that I can unpack a tuple
onto another Tuple so let me show you
what I mean by that so now that I have
packed one two three and four Tuple into
T let's unpack it into another Tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this Tuple and I put this
into T alright now let's see what I mean
by unpacking something onto something
let's see what's the what what happens
when I put a if I just want to see
what's in a it actually gives me the
value one if I see what's in B it gives
me the value 2 if I see what's in three
invalid 3 and D gives me value four so
essentially if you think of it what I
have done is I have matched this Tuple
then put it into T and then put that
Tuple T into this Tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been or
a better way to say this would be the
element one has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a two has been unpacked
onto B 3 has been unpacked onto C 4 has
been unpacked onto D to show you what
I've done in a single line is
essentially this this is essentially
what I've done
I have assigned 1 to a 2 to B 3 to C 4
to D I have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this Tuple and
the elements of this Tuple uh should be
equal so if there are four elements here
there should be four elements here all
right in fact another very important
thing about or a neat feature is that we
don't really need to mention the
parenthesis when we're doing this uh
unpacking or packing so if I did X comma
y comma Z if I did it like this if I put
say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a valid
way of packing and unpacking so now if I
see what's the value in X it is actually
five if I see what's the value in y it
is six if I see what is the value of x
and z it should give me a tuple
containing five and seven as you can see
over here so this is a neat feature of
tuples called packing and tracking in
this video we will cover Concepts
surrounding dictionaries dictionaries
are another type of composite data type
in Python there are also a collection of
objects much like tuples and lists and
like lists they are also mutable Dynamic
and can be nested however a key
difference and property of dictionaries
is that they are unordered items and
dictionaries are paired using keys
unlike enlists and tuples where the
objects are assigned numerical indexes
to define a dictionary we use curly
braces each key value pair in this
dictionary in a dictionary is separated
using commas and the key and values
themselves in a pair are separated using
a colon let's look at an example this is
a dictionary where I have three key
value pairs as you can see they have
been separated by colons and each repair
themselves are separated by commas and
these are enclosed in curly braces to
define the whole dictionary in this
example the these are the keys banana
apple and grape and their respective
values are yellow red and green so this
is very important that in this
particular data type we have what we
call a key and that key is assigned a
value and we can have multiple such
pairings and we have three such pairs in
this particular example another example
or the or another type of way to define
a dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see I
have inputted two value or two object
tuples this is a tuple this is etiopal
and this is a tuple and when I use it in
a dict function when I place it within a
list what python will do is it will
consider the first element of each Tuple
as a key and the second element of each
Tuple as its respective value now if I
check what's in D as you can see the key
banana has a value yellow the key apple
has a value right the key grape has a
value green so this is another way of
defining dictionaries an important note
over here is that the the objects that
we use for Keys have to be of an
immutable data type so we cannot use for
example lists as an example of keys but
we can use say integers or strings for
our dictionary Keys also Keys have to be
unique when it comes to a dictionary you
cannot have two different keys with uh
or should I say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have immutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if I
created a dictionary with a key say
banana and if I give if I associate it
with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overwrites the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I gave it
a value yellow or say green if I created
another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value gold
what if I wanted to add a new pair you
know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as as you can see over here now what if
I wanted to remove if I wanted to remove
a key value pair from my dictionary I
can use the delete function which is
called by using this the Del function
now how do I do it see if I want to
remove the key value Apple in Red so all
I have to do is do del d and within
square brackets I have to only mention
the key I don't even need to mention the
value just the key so you can probably
draw parallels in how we use indexes
when it comes to lists and tuples and
even strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I oops I
think red is actually not a key as you
can see red is a value my key is Apple
actually it's not red it's apple as you
can see now if I see my dictionary the
key apple and its value red has been
removed so these are some of the
operation questions that we can do for
dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is enter
a key inside the parenthesis and it will
get the value associated with that key
so if I gave the key grip let's see what
value is associated with it as you can
see it's green there is also a function
called items that Returns the key and
value pairs in our dictionary as a list
of two object tuples where the first
object is the key and the second object
is the Tuple so let's see what it does
as you can see it gave me a list and in
this list the objects inside the list
are two object pupils where the first
object is always the key and the second
is the value and and it's the same for
each of the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what uh the next
so the next function is Keys let's see
what the keys function does as you can
see it returns a list of all the unique
Keys within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered key value pair
that is present in our dictionary so the
last centered pair was watermelon key
watermelon with the value red and that's
what has popped out when we give this
function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if I had a dictionary let's say I'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called KV so as I had mentioned I will
use two object tuples in this case and
say give this also a value green all
right and another pair would be say
mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called key V with value green
and another key mango with a value
yellow and I already have a dictionary D
with these values all right now if I
want to merge these two dictionaries I
can use the update function what I do is
say if I want to merge D with X or x
with d only the ordering will change and
that doesn't really matter when it comes
to dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original Dictionary d
as you can see I have my original ones
here and I have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video I will explain what we
call the type hierarchy or the standard
type
fighting it's also known as the data
model in Python and it probably has
other names so essentially in the what
we do or what we speak about in this is
uh how the different types that we use
in Python are categorized and classified
and what are their subtypes so it's
important to note before we continue
further that there in future versions of
python there might be new types that are
introduced or the existing ones may be
modified but it's safe to say that what
I will speak about in this video will
still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the non-type
uh it's accessed through the built-in
name none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote
um functions or it's you it's returned
as the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it uh then there is the
ellipses uh ellipse is something that
you might encounter later it is accessed
through the built-in name Ellipsis
um it is used to indicate the presence
of this particular
um syntax this particular symbol or
expression uh or syntax in a slice its
truth value is true again don't worry
too much about ellipses right now next
is numbers and numbers is something that
we are very familiar with we've seen
we've worked with numbers a lot they are
an immutable type they are created
through numeric literals and they are
the outputs of arithmetic expressions
and built-in arithmetic functions its
subtypes are integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers
um within integers you have plain
integers that represent numbers in the
range uh this number and this number so
this this number is basically the
largest positive value that you can
represent using 32 bit notation induce
complement and this is the equivalent a
for the the negative the negative side
long in teachers on the other hand are
used to represent numbers in an
unlimited range that is only subject to
the available memory of your system so
these are two types of integers and as
we know floating Point numbers represent
Machine level double Precision floating
Point numbers or numbers with a decimal
point and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating Point number that represents a
real part and a floating Point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed by natural numbers
so each element in a sequence has an
index and that index is a natural number
the different types of sequences are
based on the mutability whether the
objects can be changed or not is
essentially what we mean by mutability
right once we create an object whether
we can modify I don't know and that is
how we differentiate different types of
sequences so there are mutable and there
are immutable types now the different
types of immutable ones are strings we
know what strings are they are sequences
that contain characters Unicode is the
other immutable sequence and then there
are tuples uh tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain Unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in Python and that is
lists lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects finally we have
well not finally but next we have
mappings and mappings are again
um sets of objects but these objects are
now indexed using arbitrary index sets
you know the difference between a
mapping and a sequence you could
consider sequences are ordered but
mappings are not ordered and the index
is given to the objects and sequences
are always numbers they're natural
numbers whereas in mappings they are not
natural numbers but they are certain
arbitrary objects that we can set for
ourselves again in Python there is only
one built in standard mapping type that
is the dictionary dictionaries are there
they represent finite sets of objects
indexed by nearly arbitrary values the
only condition is that these indexes
must be of an immutable data type so
these uh so what I have mentioned until
now are probably the most common data
types that we encounter or that we have
encountered now so next types are like
callable types such as user defined
functions user defined methods built-in
functions built-in methods classes and
class instances so again callable types
as a whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming and methods and
functions and such the other type are
modules so modules are module objects or
modules essentially are referenced or
called using the import function again
modules can be considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we that contain
various different methods and functions
and objects and classes within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will well during the course of this
tutorial we or during the course of this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types finally
there are internal types that are used
by python interpreter again this is
something that does not concern us right
now but just know that The Interpreter
for python uses these data types for its
functioning in this video I will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in Python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication and let's go
over them one by one so so a simple
addition operation would be like five
plus six giving me the value 11 I can do
5 minus 3 that's subtraction similarly I
can do a multiplication using five say
five into two there's division where I
use the backslash so say I did division
of 8 divided by 2. now you might
encounter another type of division which
is called the flow division where we use
a double backslash and what this does is
it returns us the largest whole number
that is lesser than the result of our
division so the division difference
between the float Division and and the
normal fluid and the floor division or
the single and the double backslash is
this say I did 9 divided by 2 using a
single backslash it should give me as
you can see 4.5 right so this is the
actual value now let's see what happens
when I do 9 double backslash two it will
give me 4 which is the largest number
lesser than or equal to 4.5 that is also
a whole number so this is what we call
Floor division essentially finally we
also have if we want to raise something
to the power or something so if I want
to do fire say 6 raised to the power 3
because I would use double asterisks and
this is how I would do it it'll give me
216 as you can see uh if I wanted
remainder between the division between
two different numbers I will use the
percentage sign so if I wanted the
remainder of the division between seven
and three this is how I would do it I
get the answer 1 as you can see so next
category of operations are logical
operations the first one is the logical
and operation where we use the operator
end all right so let's see what we mean
by this I am creating so as we know the
and operation returns a value true if
both the operands are true so let's
actually let's actually do this for an
example let's give this variable the
value true and this is the value false
so it should be done like this false so
now think of it like one and zero so a
one and zero is obviously zero right so
if I did A and B I should get the answer
false or zero because I'm doing true and
false so it's like doing one and zero so
if you see this I should get the answer
false if I change this to true as well
now if I do this I will get the answer
true as you can see uh the next logical
operation is the or operation where well
logical or is if either of the operands
are true then we should get the answer
to our or operation as true as well so
in this case obviously if I did or over
here it will naturally give us true if I
change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us faults if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is The Logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the value that we get is true
if the operand is false so let's take a
as we know a is false over here so if I
did not a I should get the answer true
but if I change this to true now if I do
not a I should get false as you can see
so this was The Logical operations let's
move on to the next set of operations
that is comparison operations so there
are a bunch of them let's go over them
one by one if I want to check if two
operands are equal so if I did X is say
equal to 2 and now Y is equal to 3. if I
want to check if they are equal I will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal I will get the value true
if they aren't either I'll get value
false as you can see since X is 2 and Y
is 3 as you can see X and why are not
the same so there's false they are not
equal if I change this also to 2 now I
will get the answer to another the next
comparison is the not equal to or where
we use the exclamation sign so over here
this is this um the result of this is
true if X and Y are not actually it's
the same so I should get false over here
as you can see but if I change this to
say 5 now I will get true because X is
not equal to Y in this case the next one
is greater than so if I did X greater
than y as we can see 2 is not greater
than 5 I will get false over here
similarly there is a lesser than if I
did X lesser than y I should get true
over here as you can see well there's
also a greater than or equal to and
lesser than or equal to we simply add
the equal to sign here so let's see now
if I say x is less than or equal to 3 I
should get true because X is 2 and if I
put 2 here I should also get true but
what if I put 1 here since X is equal to
2 and 2 is not less than equal to 1 this
is a false statement and I can do the
same thing with like this using the
greater than equal to now it's true
because 2 is actually greater than equal
to 1. and so this was comparison
operations the next set of operations
that we can do in Python are assignment
operations we've already seen a whole
bunch we've already been assigning
values to variables we've been doing
assignments throughout already but let's
go over them and see some of the
assignment operations so as we already
know the equal to operation is assigning
everything that is on the or the value
on the right hand side of the equal to
sign to what is on the left so if I did
a is equal to 5 plus 6 it will assign
the value of 5 plus 6 or 11 to a let's
check what's in a as you can see it is
11. there is a plus equal to sign and
what this does is so for example if I
did say a now since a is 11 let's create
another variable called B and call this
5 all right so now if I did a plus equal
to B what this will do is it will add B
to a and then store it in a so let's see
what this does once I do this now let's
check what's in a it should be 5 plus 11
as you can see 16. so this a plus this
is this plus equal to sine is
essentially the same as doing a is equal
to a plus b it's essentially the same
thing they're both the same uh there's a
similar thing for this the negative or
subtraction as well minus equal to so
now that a is 16 and B is still 5 of
course if I did minus equal to B now I'm
subtracting the value 5 from 16 so I
should get a is equal to 11 again as you
can see here and this is the equivalent
of doing a minus B A is equal to a minus
B I mean as you can see so uh the next
similar like assignment operation let's
create a is equal to say 6 in this case
and say B is equal to I will say 2 right
now if I do a star star equal to B what
this does is it multiplies B to a and
then assigns it back to a so if I see
what's in a now it should be 12 as you
can see here similarly there is similar
thing for subtraction as well so if I
did a is equal to 6 and B is equal to 2
and if I did a sorry for division so if
I did a division symbol and equal to
sine and then if I give B what it will
do is it will divide a by b or 6 by 2
and it will assign that back to a so my
value in a should be 3 as you can see
here 3.0 obviously this is a single uh
single backslash so this is a float
division the resultant of a single
backslash is always a float I can do the
same thing with a double backslash so
let's see if I did a is equal to 7 now
and then B is equal to 3. now if I did a
double backslash equal to B now it will
do the same division but uh it will do a
floor function so it should give me 2 in
this case if I did the same thing with a
single backslash just to show you the
difference between single backslash and
double backslash division in this case
it will give me
um the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment uh say a is equal to say 5
now B is equal to 2 now if I do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 I mean the
it should give me it will assign the uh
it will take the modulus in both sides
and then assign it to the left hand
upper end now let's see what's in a as
you can see it it did a divided by 2 the
modular symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by B and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if I have a is equal to say so 5 b is
equal to 2 and I want to raise a by if I
wanted to raise the value of a by the
value of B and then store that back in a
this is how I would do it so it should
be 5 to the power 2 which is 25 as you
can see here so this is assignment
operations so finally we move on to uh
two special sets of operators one is the
identity set identity operators and the
other is the membership operators uh
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to one thousand and one
and B is equal to
1000 plus one all right if I did a is
equal to 2. this is an equality check
are they the same values true now if I
say a is B let's see what happens as you
can see it's false this is because this
object and this object are not the same
and this is what the is Operation does
uh we can confirm this by checking the
ID of a the ID of a gives us some value
like this and the ID of B gives us as
you can see a different value so the two
objects are not located in the same
place the memory as we have seen using
the ID function and that is what we
check uh through the is operator and the
is not is essentially just the opposite
of that so so that is the identity
operator now the membership operator is
used for checking whether something is
present in a sequence or not so let's
create a sequence I will create a list
to show in this example my list is one
two and three basically simple list with
three integer objects one two and three
I will check whether now say 2 in a so
is 2 in a if it is it will give me true
as you can see is 5 in a it should give
me false because 5 is not in a and the a
naught n operator is just the opposite
of that it checks the other condition
essentially so this is the membership
operators in Python in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
Python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in Python so starting off
what is this math module well the python
map module is an important library or a
feature that is uh designed to deal with
mathematical operations this math module
is part of the basic python installation
so you don't have to install this
separately to use this math module all
you have to do is import this module and
this is how you would do it you just do
import math and this will import your
math module for you to use in your
programming and in this in the course of
this video I will be showing you certain
Concepts surrounding the math module
such as what are the constants that come
with the mass module some of the
arithmetic functions the logarithmetic
functions power functions and even
trigonometric functions that we can do
using this math module and the function
inside the math module so starting off
let's look at some of the constants that
are part of this so as you can see the
standard constants are available in this
module are Pi there is Tau there is
Euler's number Nan which is a special
it's a it's a programming specific
concept and infinity so let's look at
this one by one so starting off our
first constant is pi
um Pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circles circumference
to its diameter and Pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot Define it
in terms of of a specific fraction but
it can be approximated to the fraction
22 by 7. so how do we access this Pi
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the match module
all you have to do is do match dot pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default thing for python that if
you call the pi a constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle 3 it can be an N
units three meters or whatever you want
and you want to find out it's say
circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if I had to find the circumference of a
circle in my C in my code for some
application with the radius 3 however
all I would have to do is use the
formula 2 pi r and to call the value 2
pi r instead of specifically writing
3.14 something I can just use this
function math dot pi over here and then
I can enter the r as you can see it will
return me the radius as you can see so
moving on uh the next constant that we
will talk about is Tau Tau is similar to
Pi in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius Pi is the
ratio of a circle circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio for
circles circumference to its radius so
important to know this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
2 times the value of pi this is by
definition and much like Pi if you call
the Tau constant in you from the math
module it will also return you a float
number and to find that this is the
function that we use this is the syntax
so as you can see this is this is
actually two times the value of pi 6.283
and even this is returned correct up to
15 places to the right of the decimal
point and this is by default uh next
constant is the Euler's number the
Euler's number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of uh in the scientific community in the
mathematical Community
um you will be using the Euler's number
probably a lot as a if if you move into
data science or AI or something like
that so what is the Euler's number it is
uh it is the base of the natural
logarithm if you know what the natural
logarithm is it is used to calculate
rates of growth over rates of Decay and
as with number is a constants like pi
and Tau even the Euler's number is an
irrational number with infinite decimal
places uh the value of the Euler's
number in short it's denoted by the
small letter e so this value of e is our
usually approximated around 2.718 so how
do we call this constant is simply as
math dot e this is how we do it so you
get this value again this is also a
float and it's correct up to 15 decimal
places so the next concept that we will
be talking about is infinity now
Infinity is a it's more of a
mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because Infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called Infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive Infinity is something that is
higher than any known number to us and
negative Infinity is lower than any
known number to us so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant Infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this it might look like a string to
you but this is actually a special type
in Python
um which is not a string this is all
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this Infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can you can
consider as an equivalent to a float but
um it's not it's not a typical float
that we know like you know 3.14 or 2.71
the value of method.inst will give us
INF and this is this INF is actually not
a string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when I do a
type when I check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in Python 3.5 a special
type known as math.inf it returns this
INF data type which is equivalent waste
float so this is this is how we use
Infinity if you wanted to get the value
of say minus infinity all you would have
to do is match dot INF with a minus sign
preceding this constant and you will get
minus INF now let's check if the
concepts or the properties of infinity
are maintained you know like every a
positive Infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
Infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this
um so I will take method in and I will
do a check is this greater than say some
really large number something that comes
off the top of my head immediately okay
so let's see if it's if this is true
then this is conceptually correct and as
you can see it is true in fact I can
change this number to anything as large
as I want this will be true because
Infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know and similarly if I
did minus math dot in INF and I checked
some very small number you know a very
very small negative number so just
consider some minus 10 to the power
something right this should also be true
uh sorry it should be in a smaller sense
symbol this should also be true because
I'm checking minus infinity is smaller
than any known number to us and it is
true as you can see so it's very uh also
if you did a if you did something like
so let's say if we do let's add
something to this you know it's a number
so we should be able to do arithmetic on
this let's actually see what happens
when I add say 10 to positive Infinity
it actually gives us the same value back
infinity because uh intuitively we know
that infinity plus anything is still
going to be Infinity right and this is
exactly what python does for us even if
we add a number to this the math dot INF
or the infinity constant in Python it
will still give us uh the same value the
same data type of INF or Infinity
similarly if we subtracted something
from the negative of maths.inf you know
uh say minus say again let's say minus
100 so if you subtract something from
minus infinity we're technically still
minus infinity itself so this will again
give us minus and minus minus INF as you
can see and this is absolutely what we
need and this is a very very interesting
feature in Python uh finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the na
a n or the not a number constant so this
is not really a mathematical constant
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that it's used to is
used to denote invalid inputs or in it's
used to indicate a certain places where
say a variable that should have a number
it's been corrupted for whatever reason
and it it now has a text or a symbol and
our code throws an error then in these
in these cases where python expects a
number from us or from your code and it
does not get it it will throw you a n a
n value and this is usually used in
cases where you have errors in your code
so again just to check like what this
this constant like how to call it this
is how you actually do it maths.nan and
it will give you a data type called Nan
also much like the infinity cons
constant let's see what's the type of
this this constant again might look like
a string to you but of course this is
not a string this is enough a numerical
concept and as you can see it's still a
float so this is like um it's another
special uh data type that was created
for specifically this case where uh it's
some it's the equivalent of a float but
um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the using
the math module so some of the common
arithmetic functions that are available
to us are factorials the ceiling
operation floor operation uh there's
permutations there's combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the LCM or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually is defined like
this math dot factorial all right so now
what we pass in between the parenthesis
will be uh what we calculate the
factorial for as you know factorial is
so factorial is always for a positive
integer and the factorial for say a
number 10 would mean 10 times 9 times 8
times 7 so on until the number one
obviously factor is only defined for
positive integers uh it is not defined
for negative values or it's uh and it's
also not defined for decimal values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know
um so let's say we pass match dot
factorial for six and let's see what's
the value so this is exactly what we
expect so we expect the value of 6 times
5 times 4 times 3 times 2 uh that is
actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass 0 this should give us one
since we know 0 factorial is one now
let's see in error case where we pass a
minus 5 as you can see this will throw
us and error because factors are not
defined for negative numbers now Moving
On Let's uh so the next function that
we'll talk about is the ceiling function
so the ceiling function is defined using
math dot CL as you see here so again we
pass the number that we want the ceiling
for in between the parenthesis so what
is the Searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if I give you 6.6 and
I asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at it now a negative number
so minus 12.3 uh an integer that is
greater than minus 12.3 is is minus 12
the smallest integer that is greater
than minus 7.3 and this should give you
12 as you can minus 12 as you can see
here a similar function is the floor
function which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than whatever value we pass
between the parenthesis so if I gave it
2.3 it should give me the value 2. again
if we pass integers it will just give us
the integer itself again that is to
reiterate this ceiling and four
functions they give you into integer
values so the floor function will give
you the largest integer that is smaller
than what we pass over here so let's
look at 6.7 so the largest integer that
is smaller than 6.7 is 6 and as you can
see this is our answer over here uh the
next function that we will look at is
the truncate function the transcript
function is defined using this truncate
is very similar to what we have seen
this is how we Define the truncate
function uh it is very similar to the
ceiling and floor uh in the truncate
function what we do is
um we pass a decimal value a float
number to the between between the
parenthesis and what we get back is the
number without the decimal component so
only the integral component so if I gave
it 7.8 for example it will give me only
the seven part it will return me only
the seven part and it will chop away the
point eight part if I gave it minus 12.3
uh it will chop away the 0.3 part and
give me only minus 12 back so let's look
at an example 8.9 it should give me only
8 as you can see here see I did minus 8
or minus
6.9 it should give me -6 so you can
think of truncate function as it does
the floor function for positive values
and it does the ceiling function for
negative values because it rounds down
and rounds up respectively for positive
and negative values so now let's look at
the next set of arithmetic functions
um let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parenthesis I
have to pass two values n and K okay so
I have to pass n n and a k the K has to
be less than or equal to n because the
permutation as you know is uh the number
of ways in which we can permute from n
objects K Tire K different objects uh so
what this mathematically what this is is
um permutation of N and K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial so if I
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value fifteen one fifty one
thousand two hundred similarly there is
a combination function and this is a
combinations of permutations are used a
lot in probability so if you're going to
move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in machine learning AI
you will be using these functions quite
a bit
um so the combination function again you
pass an n and a k again the N should be
greater than or equal to this K what
this evaluates is n factorial divided by
n minus K factorial times K factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6. so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
um our gcd and LCM as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor LCM is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
um since uh I cannot show you that
because I don't have the absolute latest
version of python on my system but using
the
math.gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
will do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if I give these say for
example if I gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the LCM
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst or
whatever we pass over here so if I
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the LCM of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or uh if you have python 3.9
or after that uh you will have access to
these functions as well if you when you
import the math module so that was for
the arithmetic uh functions let's move
on to the next section which are power
and logarithmetic logarithmic functions
so let's start off with the power
function
um there are two there are uh multiple
ways you can actually do a power
function in math in Python so you can do
something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt uh module math and
you can use the pow or the power
function which is this is how you do it
and if I had to do same 2 to the power 3
I would just pass 2 and 3 has arguments
like this and it should give me the
value as you can see 8 over here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
module but it's still part of the base
python use this as well and you can do
the same thing pow 2 and 3 it should
give you the value 8 again the you know
you might ask what's the difference
between these two functions well it's
not much for at least in the beginner
standpoint it's not that much uh just
note that the maths dot power function
is slightly computationally faster than
the simple power function so yeah moving
on their next topic would be the next
function that we'll discuss is the
exponential function which is defined
like this again exponential function is
again e to the power something so if I
did exponential of 3 this would give me
e to the power 3. so as you can see oh
of course I did not Define the module
beforehand so math.exp now when I do
this it should it will give me some
value which is basically Euler's number
or e to the power 3. so this was the
exponential function and let's look at
an example so we will look at the
example of rate of d k and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of Decay
um uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive elements that is
present in a substance after a certain
amount of time so the the the the the
expression is uh something like the
initial amount of radioactive elements
that were present uh right at the
beginning times the exponent of minus
693 times t t for time divided by the
time period the half-life time uh so
let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see the uh so
this will give me the remaining amount
of radioactive elements right so let's
uh slide down remaining let's assign
this to a variable remaining so the
initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100
um the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
um Half-Life is around I don't know
let's give some value say three or
something again this is uh the details
are not important so this will I'm using
the math dot exponential function over
here as you can see and for these values
uh now when I check what's the value of
remaining after I calculated something
uh so this is it's basically what this
tells me is that I started off with 100
units of some radioactive element
um and in 10 years if this is what is
left so yeah so this is how we would use
say the X exponential functions in a
particular example of ours so next the
next type of again functions are
logarithmic functions so let's look at
some of these algorithmic functions that
are part of the math module so basic log
function would be written like this math
DOT log in in between this I would pass
the number that I want the log for by
default if I just pass one number it
will it will calculate the log of 8 to
the base of e as we know e is the
Euler's number so let's see what it does
in this case gives me some value what if
I wanted to specify a particular base
well I would pass a second argument in
this case I want to find the log of a to
the base 2 this should be the value 3 as
you can see over here uh there are two
specific functions that are also
provided in this math module that is log
2 uh what this will do is again it will
again I have to just pass one argument
and this will automatically find the
value of the log of 8 to the base 2. as
you can see here similarly there is a
math DOT log 10 function if I give if I
did this I will find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was a logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math the square root function is
Mass dot sqrt again we passed what we
want over here if we want the square
root of say 49 this should give me the
value 7 as you can see finally maybe
move on to the final set of functions
that we can do using this math module uh
they are trigonometric functions and
they are hyperbolic functions so let's
start off with some of the trigonometric
functions as we know
um we can do sine we can do cosine and
tan uh some of the basic functions the
way we would do it is math DOT sign in
between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular angle
and this angle must be passed in radians
and this is very important to note we do
not pass it in degrees but in radians so
if I say past sine of 3.14 as we know
3.14 is an approximation of the value by
sine Pi is supposed to be in fact it's
supposed to be zero so let's see we get
something close 0 again since this is an
approximation it won't give us the exact
value similarly we can use math dot cos
to find the value of a particular angle
if you want to find yeah if you want to
find the value of the sorry the cost of
a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case we wanted to find the
tan similarly we have the next set for
arc sine and the arc cosines of the
certain of angles so to use to find the
arc sine for example we would use a DOT
sign I mean sorry a sign for R cosine we
would use this and for r10 we would use
this the next set would be hyperbolic
functions again hyperbolic functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas again the details don't have
to be you don't have to know the details
you just should you should know that if
you wanted to say for example find out
the hyperbolic sign of n and a of an
angle we would use math dot sine H and
we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos H tan it would be
tan H and if we wanted to find the
inverse of the hyperbolic inverse we
what we would do is what we would do is
use a so we would use a tan H if you
wanted to find the hyperbolic inverse uh
of sine we would use a sine H and
similarly for cos it would be cos a COS
H in this video we will learn about
conditional statements and we will learn
about how do we create these control
structures where we have these
conditional statements we will learn
about the keywords if we use in Python
to create a conditional statement block
the if keyword the alif keyword and the
else keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in Python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
Python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this pictorial if there's an if
statement there is a expression uh there
is this a block of code which if you can
actually see is slightly indented to the
rest of the code uh and then we have the
rest of the rest of our code after that
so what we're looking at is this so this
is our if statement block
um now let's let's break this down so
what is this expression that we're
speaking of uh an expression in this
context is a Boolean expression which
evaluates to a true or false statement
so when we are speaking about the if
statement we have an expression and if
this expression evaluates to true then
we X execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if the statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks uh otherwise if it's
false we move on to the next the next
statement block or the beginning of a
new statement uh so let's look at an
example to further understand this let's
take this if statement over here as you
can see in this if statement I have this
expression 50 greater than 30. so what
python is going to do now is it's going
to check whether 50 is greater than 30
and it's going to check in a Boolean
context if this is true then we can move
on to the next portion which is this but
if it is false then we will skip this so
let's see what this uh what happens over
here so since we know that 50 is indeed
greater than 30 this is a true
expression we move on to this block of
code which is saying that print 50 is
indeed a larger number than 30. so let's
see if this actually gets printed so as
you can see we get this uh the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at what happens if I
gave a false expression now I'm checking
if 50 is lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if I have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed and in fact my print statement
is just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in Python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on
um let's move on to the topic of
indentation in in Python so as you can
see this uh this if statement is an
example of a control structure so
without moving without defining uh what
a control control structure is in detail
control structures consists of these
conditionals or Loops or iterations if
you will so all of these control
structures involve heavy indentation so
so what does an indentation mean well
what if I gave you an example say I gave
you some variable called H and I wrote
20 over here now if I give you an if
statement saying if age is greater than
10 now uh it's very important to note
that when I'm defining an if statement I
need this colon otherwise this if
statement is not defined so this colon
is important uh anyways so now I'm
checking this expression if age is
greater than 10. now what is this what
happens if H is greater than 10 now what
if I want python to do something only if
age is greater than 10 well how do I
tell python that there is a piece of
code or a section of code that I want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if I want say if I want
this line this person is an adult again
this is some random line where I'm
assuming age is pertaining to this adult
all right or this person so if I have
this variable age where I write this
number 20 which denotes the age of some
person and I'm doing a check if age is
greater than 10 actually let's be
specific here well the adult age for
most people is 18 in most countries so
let's see if age is greater than 18. now
if I'm doing this check uh I want to
print this statement only if this person
is a person's age is above 20 above 18
so how do I tell python that I only want
this statement to be uh executed only
during this if this condition is met
whereas this is where indentation comes
into play and as you can see exactly as
you can see uh this part this portion of
the code is slightly indented compared
to the if statement so when this
condition is met then only do we move on
to this if this condition is not met we
move on to whatever the next section of
code will be like whatever whatever code
that we have after this if statement so
let's see so this since this condition
is actually met as you can see this
print statement is actually executed so
this is the importance of indentation
now we will see uh in as we move as we
learn more about if statements and else
statements and alif statements how
indentation plays a key role in defining
what we want as an output when a certain
condition is met all right so for now
it's very important to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
Python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the C language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
programming so you might say that so
different people have different opinions
on an indentation the general consensus
is that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one of the facets
of Python Programming is the indentation
and the easy readability of it anyways
moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this list or
let's actually just copy this example
that I have written over here as you can
see what I am doing in this piece of
code is I have a list X where I have
this integer 50 I have two strings get
an Apple now I want to check a bunch of
things so I want to check if 60 is an X
and I also want to check if the string
cat is an X and I want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
I want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the L if which is kind of a
short form for else if so we use the L
if keyword so it so what this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is a keyword used
in our blog to tell python that if none
of our earlier Expressions have been
true then do what is in the uh there
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is only we only Reach
This LL statement in case all of the
earlier conditions have not been met or
have come to be false and not true so
let's look at this particular code
example so we have a list of 50 cat and
apple and I'm my first expression that
I'm checking is is 60 in X so this is
how we check actually so if 60 and X
should be read as is 60 in the list X so
is this 16 the licks list X well
actually no we don't have the object 60
so this part is not executed we move on
to the next condition is the string cat
in X well actually it is the string cat
is indeed in X so we move on to this
statement block which is within the
condition that is met which is print cat
is in list X and you will see that none
of the other statement blocks will be
executed because we have met our
condition over here so if I execute this
as you can see that the print statement
cat is in this text is what is actually
executed and we do not execute this
obviously because it is false and we do
not even check or we do not even move on
to the statement because well we have a
condition mat over here so it's a one
thing that is important to note is that
we can use as many alif statements to
check for as many conditions that we we
want to check for but it's very
important that we only use and if we are
using that we only use one else
statement and only at the end of our
block okay so moving on now I'm going to
show you a very neat example about how
python actually does its uh these
condition checkings so it's very
important to note that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so we do not even
consider the next statements and we
directly leave this if statement block
so let's look at this example over here
now in this example that I have over
here is where I've stored the string cat
in X now I have three uh I have three
conditions that I'm checking I'm
checking is 50 greater than 60. I am
checking if the value of x is indeed cat
and I'm checking I'm some random
expression 1 divided by 0. this is not
even a check this is literally just
checking if 1 divided by 0 is true or
false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so let's see what
happens when I execute this statement
now typically if I wrote 1 divided by 0
python will throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by zero that is an
error error statement so let's see what
happens when I do this actually as you
can see I have a statement being printed
but I have no error even though I gave
it wrong I gave an error statement in 1
divided by 0 well now you might ask why
is that so well it's simply because I
have actually never reached this
condition I have not even uh python is
not bothered looking at this because if
you actually see there is a condition
previous to this uh over here which is
met and which is true so we move on to
this block we execute this block and we
forget about the rest of the code so we
don't actually get to this error
statement which is an interesting thing
and which is an example that I have
shown uh to show you that once a
condition is met in an if statement
block we do not look at any of the
further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally
um I have one one small topic that I
would like to share with you is the
conditional expressions or the pythons
ternary operator now this is slightly
different to the if statement that we
have talked about up until now uh in the
sense that it is not a control structure
so what this actually is is more of an
operator that defines some expert
question so let's see what I'm trying to
say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the Syntax for what
I'm trying to talk about this ternary
operator so let's look at this example
and let's see what I'm trying to do over
here so I have this variable age all
right and this age is 26. now X now just
just read this statement X is equal to
adult if age is greater than 18 else
child now I could have done an elaborate
control structure with an if statement
then an indentation within that if
statement and then
um I could have written else and then
another indentation and I would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that I have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable X and this uh what value
I'm assigning to X depends on if this
condition is true or false so as you can
see the condition says is age 18 uh
greater than 18. so if this is true then
I assign this particular string if it is
false then I go to the the else
statement and I assign this so since age
26 is greater than 18 I should assign
the string adult to X and as you can see
if I execute this and check what is an X
you can see adult is indeed in X so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um it's it's a it's probably
a more it's it's a better looking way uh
to perform simple else uh Sim simple if
and else statements where you don't want
to create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we let's uh we we make a short
note on the pass statement uh in Python
so the path statement or the pass
keyword is a a place where it is is a
placeholder of sorts so what if I had an
if statement and I'm writing a piece of
code but I don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true
um but I don't know what to do if this
statement was true how do I tell python
well let's just keep it a hold for now
and I might put something into this
block later in the future well I would
use the pass statement so if I had this
say this some condition again so I'm
checking age is greater than 18 but I
don't know what to do with this I would
just simply use this past statement and
this basically does nothing uh it it's a
way to it's it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future I
might have I might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently I don't have
anything to place over here so I just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is a way where you can use a pass
statement in if and as statement or if
an else control structures in this video
we will be I will introduce you to the
concept of iterations in Python and we
will be speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration in Python otherwise
known as the while loop so let's look at
what an iteration means an iteration is
uh executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
in definite iterations in Python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to Define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
just like NFL statements a set of
statements where what happens here is
following the while keyword we have this
expression where this expression is
evaluated in a Boolean context again we
check if this expression evaluates true
or false and if it is true we execute
all the statements or the statement
block that is indented below this file
statement this is another example of
control structure much like FNL state in
blocks where we use a lot of indentation
so let's look at a basic example now of
while loop so let's copy this example
and let's see what this does so I have a
variable n where I am assigning it a
value 0. this is called an initializing
process and it's very important to note
that most while Loops consist of an
expression which contains a variable a
control variable uh which is usually
initialized prior to starting the loop
and then this control variable is
typically very modified somewhere within
the main Loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and I am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0. so let's move into the loop now
so the loop has this wire keyword as you
can see followed by a an expression n
lesser than or equal to 5. now what this
is is an expression which is going to
check if it's true or false is n lesser
than or equal to 5 and as long as this
expression is true we will continue
you're doing whatever is indented below
this y statement and what is below this
y statement is a print statement first
of all which says value of n is and it
basically prints a value of n in that
particular iteration and as you can see
this uh compound assignment where we add
the value of n uh by 1 and we assign it
back to n so what this is uh let's see
what this does actually let's execute
this and see what this does uh important
to note the value of n again is
initialized at zero so this while loop
will keep going on until the value of n
remains lesser than or equal to 5. so as
you can see I have the execution of this
uh particular block of code or this
while loop where I get the multiple
different iterations of this print
statement that you can see here the
first iteration it says value of n is 0
then its value of n is 1. what I'm doing
is I am writing I am assigned I am
writing uh the value of n multiple times
uh and each time the value of n is
written over here based on what
iteration it is so what is happening
actually is uh the initially the value
of n is 0 and I print the statement
value of n is 0. now I add uh the value
of what is In N by 1. so now what is the
value of n so again we do this check so
after this first iteration we come back
or like once this whole block of code is
executed we again come back to this
expression and we again check if the
statement is true so now that the value
of n is actually 1 if this statement is
still true so again we execute this and
as that you can see over here value of n
is 1. now again we add the value of n by
1 and again we go back here once this uh
this block is executed and we check if
this statement is true again and as you
can see the value of n when it's 2 is
still uh making sure that this
expression is true and this keeps
happening until the value of n is
greater than 5. so once the value of n
becomes 6 this condition is no longer
met and finally we do not execute the
statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
loop so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't uh we don't
necessarily have to Define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use it rubles in an example of an
iterable is the list so let's look at
this list and let's look at this whole
block all right so I created this list a
which contains five objects one two
three four and five all integer objects
and I have another variable will ax
where I store the integer one now I'm
this while statement now it might look
confusing now it says it says while a
now what is a well a is not uh your
typical expression where you're making
sure if some condition is being met or
not but this the way you read this is
while a exists so in the context of a
list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we uh do like we
we have this value X where we uh we're
doing this this we're printing this is
iteration number and we pass X so the
first iteration obviously pass X is
equal to 1 and then we add X by 1 and
then the the second iteration should
pass this is iteration number two and
then so on and finally we have another
statement within this block called the a
called the pop statement where we're
popping the elements of a now as if you
would have seen the list the video on
lists the pop statement removes the
rightmost value uh from a list so if I
do a DOT pop initially it will remove 5
from this list and I will have the rest
of them again if I do pop it will remove
4 from this list and then you will have
the rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so that I'll also print the list a each
uh during each iteration and let's see
what happens over here as you can see
what is happening out here is while a or
while a has elements we are going to
continue doing this y statement whatever
is within it so in the first iteration
obviously we have all of it uh and it is
iteration number one and as you can see
the list contains everything then I pop
it then iteration number two it again
has elements but it has lost its most
rightmost element and this keeps on
happening until the list finally has no
elements left and once the element or
invents the list has no elements left we
this expression while a evaluates to
false and we do not execute this anymore
and we leave the while low and again
let's check what is in a a should have
no elements as you can see it's an empty
list when a check written a it's an
empty list and that is why while a
return near false and we do not print
any further so this is an example of
using a wire statement using lists and
of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and this
is a broad topic what I mean by this is
that when when I'm saying nested while
Loops I'm actually talking about nested
control structures so we can have while
Loops within while Loops not only that
we can have FNS statements within while
Loops we can have while Loops within if
and else statements and we can have FNL
statements within FNL statements so if
you think of all of these loops and we
will even speak about four Loops in the
in the in in a in another video for
Loops again a type of control structure
so all of these are control structures
while Loops are control structures for
Loops or control structures if and as
statements are control structures all of
these are control structures and nesting
can happen within them and it does not
matter uh which is the like the parent
of the nest and then the child of the
nest we can have a while loop within an
ifnl statement you can have for Loops
within a while loop all of this is valid
in Python and uh it's one of the one of
the great features of python that is
very flexible in this way so let's look
at an example where I have a while loop
within another while loop so I am
copying this piece of code where I have
this list one two three four five and
another list first and second now my
first while loop I print I print what is
pop from a so I take a then I pop the
zeroth index so basically from the left
hand side and I print what is that all
right and then I have another while loop
where I have this list B and I'm doing
the same thing but this while loop is
within the first while loop and let's
see what happens out here so as you can
see my first uh my first iteration of
this parent while loop causes me to pop
what is the first element which is one
then I do these while loops and this is
completely executed and only then do I
go back to this first one and then I
come back and do all of this again then
I go back to this one and then I come
back into all of this again and that's
why you can see this repetition so I
have this first iteration and then I do
the second while loop then I have the
second iteration and then I do the
second while loop and I keep doing this
and this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next Topic in this sec
in this video would be break in continue
statements now break in continue
statements are ways to abruptly end
iterations uh in in a particular Loop
now you can use break in continue
statements not only in while loop where
you can use it and also in for Loops so
let's look at how we use it in while
loops and let's look at what we mean by
breaking container new statements first
of all well the break statement
terminates the loop entirely so once the
break statement is found the the
complete while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continue
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current Loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether the
expression or the or the controlling
expression is again re-evaluated and it
is checked whether the loop will execute
again or terminate this pictorial that
you can see here actually emphasizes or
it shows the difference between break
and continue so I have this while loop
and I have an expression all right I
have a bunch of statements and I have a
break command over here and I have a
continue command over here so if I
encounter the break command it will not
execute any of this in fact it will not
execute this y segment at all and it
will move on to the next piece of code
that we have but a continuous statement
if a continuous statement is income
about it in a while loop will not
completely break away but it will not uh
it will not execute the the rest of the
statements in that iteration only these
two but it will go back here it will
check this expression again and again we
will do this all over again so this is
this small uh difference between the
break and continue statements but both
are used to abruptly end an iteration in
a loop so let's look at an example of
how we use the break statement so I will
use this example where I have again I
have initialized some controlling
variable n to 0 my first Loop will check
whether n is less than equal to 5 if
this is true then I will print this
statement then I will what I'm doing
over here is I am incrementing it by one
now in my previous my earlier example
using a similar uh using the similar
example I had no like this this part was
not there so what you got was I was
printing the value of n so it was
printing as like value of n is 1 I mean
0 and then one and then two and then
three four 4 and 5 but over here I've
included a small I've nested an if
statement and within that I put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2
so once n is 2 I move on to this and I
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once so when
I have executed this I don't get the
whole value of n is 0 and then 1 and
then 2 3 4 5. I I stop at one and that
is because once n is equal to 2 I
actually do not execute this while loop
again I do not go back and execute print
value of n is 2 now in fact I break from
this whole while loop and my while loop
terminal is right then and there and
that's why you only get these two
iterations value of n is 0 and then
value of n is one okay so now I'm going
to show you a neat example of what
happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but I have added one more statement
where I print hello at each iteration so
let's see see what happens when I do
this as you can see it will print hello
after each of whatever I was doing
already now let's introduce our break
statement first of all so when I do
break well let's go back to this if
statement if his if we check this
condition then we break let's see what
happens now as you can see something
interesting has happened where we have
this first iteration completely being
executed but the second iteration kind
of stops where there's no hello and that
is because we have broken from this
while loop before the second iterations
hello was printed let's see the
difference between a break and continue
now so now I have this continuous
statement and instead of a break let's
see what happens here as you can see it
seems familiar to our first example
where we do not have any break or
continue but there is a small difference
that I want you to catch and that is
very important about this continue uh
statement so as you can see the first
iteration has value of n is 0 and then
hello then value of n is 1 but there is
no hello and this is because this is
because once this condition is actually
met we do not move on to this statement
but we go back to this expression and we
will evaluate this expression and then
once we evaluate this expression again
and it's found to be correct we do
everything the same again when we print
hello but except for that one step where
this if statement was met and we did
continue and this following statement
was not executed and that happens only
for one iteration and that is when n is
equal to equal to 2 and as you can see
that is what happens over here in one of
the iterations we may say hello and that
is the difference of the continue
statement between uh there is a
difference of the continue statement
with the break statement this video will
be an extension into that topic where we
will be looking at three examples where
we are using while Loops along with
other stuff like say if and else
statements so our first example will be
where we calculate the factorial of a
number in this example as you can see
here we are first going to ask the user
to enter a particular number for us now
this number is supposed to be an integer
once we have this integer we store it to
a variable called number now we have
this you can say this variable called
fac which does one and you we will see
how we are using it later now we know
that the factorial of 0 is 1 that's how
it's just defined so we have an if
statement checking whether our entered
number is 0 and if it is 0 we say that
the result is 1 or the factorial is one
however if we enter a number that is
greater than 0 we must calculate the
factor oil for this number and that is
what we are going to do in this else
statement block over here now in this
else statement block we have a while
loop in this while loop the condition is
checking while number is greater than or
equal to 1. so as long as this condition
is true everything within that while
loop will be executed so as long as
number is greater than equal to 1 we are
going to execute these two lines now
what do these two lines do let us see so
the first line takes the variable fac
where we had the number one stored and
we are going to store fac times number
into it number being the number that we
have inputted so in case for example we
start we entered 8 then what this will
do this line will do is 1 into 8 and it
will store that back into fac now once
that is done we move on to the next line
where we are decrementing the number
variable by one so if we have stored 8
or we have entered 8 into our input it
will become 7. now as we know 7 is still
greater than or equal to 1 so this
condition is still being met and then we
do this process again where we are going
to multiply fac this time fac stores the
value 8 and we multiply it times the new
number which is 7 now so we do 8 into 7
and then again we decrement this uh also
once we do 8 into 7 we store it back
into fac and we keep doing this where we
keep multiplying 8 times 7 and then we
decrement the number variable uh by one
and then we check this condition again
so what ends up happening is we are
going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6 into
5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1 and once
we are at 1 again when we do this
document operation the number variable
we store the value 0 and then this
condition will no longer be met so
number will be 0 and this condition will
be false and we can move out of this
while low then finally we store the
result into a variable called result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
to 6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this
um in real time once we execute this so
I'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say I enter my number 8 as I was
speaking about eight all right now that
I have entered 8 as you can see the
result that it gives me is factorial of
8 is 4 0 3 2 0 which is correct and you
can check this for yourself where it
will show you
um 8 times 7 or 8 factorial is basically
this this number okay so now in our next
example we will be looking at how we can
generate Fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at